what is your stance on cockfighting I'm
not for any type of fighting so I guess
I'm against it very good
hi there I'm aria some people spend
their whole lives looking for their soul
mates so I'm gonna do it in 48 hours
this video already feels a bit more
personal to me
so to begin my plunge into the romantic
abyss I consult with celebrated psychic
Jack Rourke and his incredible beard the
romantic in me the dreamer me that wants
to believe that soulmates exists do you
believe that soul mates exist the short
answer is no I believe that a soul mate
relationship is the relationship you
have with yourself you can have a soul
mate by embracing yourself and then it
manifests externally as a partner who
will embrace you for who you really are
we have to take off that lens so we can
see that the world is full of people who
just want to be loved - this is all you
wrote a book is there any way you can
foresee how this this challenge will go
[Music]
I'm just processing this imagery here
and trying to interpret it I think
you're gonna be surprised I think you're
gonna come out of this with a with a
couple of new friends and actually a
potential commitment potential
commitment but I do think you're gonna
start dating someone out of this we'll
see we'll see we'll see but not wanting
to leave my fade up - well fade I also
scheduled a session with ELISA a
matchmaker from successful matchmaking
company three day rule the only slight
hiccup is that I accidentally booked us
the stage that's typically reserved for
our hit mystery series buzzfeed unsolved
[Music]
practice that ELISA and other three day
rule matchmakers carefully interview
each person they meet in order to find
the best match as possible and I'm no
exception talk to me about what you do
for a living the videos I tend to
produce are a bit on the more
interesting side in the past month alone
I've married a stranger in Vegas I found
a friend on LinkedIn
it's spent a day with a foreign company
spent a day with a cam girl
I sold my headshots at a porn convention
and of course I'm also here trying to
find my soul okay so we're gonna find
you your wacky counterpart in terms of
their profession I have no real
preference of what they do
ideally they don't like run a
cockfighting ring that's so specific but
as our conversation grows deeper I
realize I'm finding myself increasingly
invested in this entire process I
haven't had a serious relationship for
almost two years now why do you think
you're single I do so many wacky things
I think it's it's hard to find someone
that really understands me and what I do
we subconsciously see people like us in
a lot of ways and it's true opposites
attract and all that good jazz but they
don't usually last and that's because
the foundation of people need to be a
little similar so they can connect and
you know if you told me you're looking
for somebody good hearted and smart and
ambitious and will challenge each other
and those are things that you will bring
to the relationship as well so when both
people do it they appreciate it in each
other the core of who you are needs to
really match up with the core if someone
else is how long is the usual turnaround
time on these things sometimes we spend
weeks looking for the right person is
there any way you could find someone for
me by a light tomorrow night well you
know I'll say it is a challenge but
challenge accepted it's okay I take it
all night I'll do it and we're gonna
find you your goofy fun-loving gal
that's gonna love what you do and love a
smile with you that's that's like all
since I wasn't sure if Alisa would be
able to find someone in time I decide to
also use the Internet to try and meet as
wide a variety of women as possible and
by the next day I received several
replies and I invite literally every
single respond deed to come in and since
I didn't have enough time to do proper
background checks I hired an actor to
pose as a production coordinator to help
screen them can you confirm that you are
over 18 years of age yes
are you a u.s. veteran have you ever
funded an international terrorist
so no I excuse me excuse me sorry sorry
sir I'm looking for finding your
soulmate Rea I also hired an actress to
test their character just hang out here
by seeing how they'd react in the face
of a sticky situation
oh hey hey hey that's got my name on it
yeah yeah no no no I I took the bus here
they didn't pick me up and luckily the
majority of them passed bingo yeah it's
mine right now you know if you need
money I can give you money okay she took
money out of this bag she just took your
ten she snagged ten bucks come back
[Music]
after I received the all-clear for my
team I meet with each woman individually
trying to learn as much about them as
possible
I'm from Geneva slits on Wow very cool
so do you speak French she's good
japako COC go to Colombia yeah I studied
political science and psychology I'm a
witch Oh I was a theater major me too
really I love theater obviously did a
production of them is what yeah we're up
ChatterBait living or dead who was your
dream dinner guest
David Bowie I actually love Princess
Diana Johnny Depp oh the rock he's my
Dwayne my rock my Johnson do you believe
in soulmates I do I definitely do know
I think it's difficult to say that there
is one person out there for you yeah I
do yeah 100% I do
I think soulmate is kind of like
something that grows over time do you
think everyone does find their soul mate
in the end eventually
I like the idea it's hard to stay
optimistic in this dating age though
it's the hope and the idea of someone
else if a Greeks thought that like we
were split in the beginning of time and
our other half is out there wandering
somewhere and we just have to like find
it I genuinely enjoy getting to know
each of them but afterwards I realize
that I'm mentally overwhelmed from all
these different people I just met and
have no idea how to proceed I think
bringing a lot of people may not have
been the best strategy I could just pick
one and then go out do something fun I
don't know but then would have it I'm
gonna make a quick phone call and I'm
gonna give you a call back and I can
hopefully give you an address in a bit
and you think she'd be able to meet me
tonight at that address
[Music]
you guys having fun in common she
doesn't take herself too seriously oh
just like you makes everyone smile
around her just like you and you guys
are totally looking for the same things
out of life when asked most women what
they're looking for Thank You Philly
conditional answers like honey tell me
that she really was concerned with the
person that you were could you make
someone laugh were you a good person and
were you happy any sort of things that
really matter when it comes down to
finding a good match for you and I can
ask for her I'm I I have no words don't
be worried you are so fantastic and the
best guy ever
honestly you deserve a good girl and a
guy you deserve but it's gonna be fun
easy that's how I describe what it felt
like to be with Sierra just at ease you
see my mind always races at a hundred
miles an hour and every time I make a
video that priority for me is always
making sure it's the best it can be
nothing else matters but as I sat there
with her as we talked and laughed and
shared things I certainly never thought
I would I realized that for the very
first time the video this video wasn't
the first thing on my mind I don't know
if she's my soul mate
but Sierra has taught me an old saying
I'd like to leave you with which goes
what is for you
will not pass you by it's a saying that
she sincerely believes in and you know
what
so do I
love to bring me sunshine
I see a smile
every place